Marvel's two Guardians of the Galaxy installments
are action-packed, exciting, and even meaningful.
Best of all, they're really funny.
Usually that humor is intentional, but sometimes,
it's a complete accident.
Which is great, because these bloopers make
us love Guardians of the Galaxy even more.
Rooker books it
You think walking and chewing gum at the same
time is hard?
Trying walking and talking!
Sure, it sounds like something you do every
day, but as actors Michael Rooker and Tom
Proctor prove here, it's not always as easy
as it seems.
"He was cargo!
And you're always going soft on him!"
"And you!
Walked us right off the set!"
"Yes, I did!
And I'm gonna do it again."
A blooper from a galaxy far, far away
Kurt Russell is a living legend, but even
legends sometimes screw up their lines.
Like in this blooper, where Russell accidentally
gives a shout out to the franchise that inspired
much of the space action in Guardians of the
Galaxy.
"Well, even where I reside out past the edge
of what's known, we've heard tell about the
man they call Star Wars."
"We could be in trouble."
Dance-off in space
In the theatrical ending to the first film,
Chris Pratt's Star-Lord uses the threat of
a dance off as a diversion.
But in this awesome outtake, Lee Pace's bad
guy Ronan the Accuser accepts the challenge,
leading to the epic showdown we've all been
waiting for.
"It's on!"
Wire work gone haywire
The Guardians of the Galaxy movies take place
on various planets with varying levels of
gravity.
To make it look realistic, the actors have
to strap themselves in for some wire work.
Sometimes the results are amazing.
And other times, this happens.
"I think we got it."
Rocket to the gag reel
Groot and Rocket Raccoon are the result of
the combined magic of CGI, the voice work
of stars Vin Diesel and Bradley Cooper, and
motion capture.
And thank goodness the movies used real-life
human stand-ins for the tree man and his trash
panda buddy, because how else would a blooper
featuring these two characters even be possible?
"I told you, you can't fit!"
"Rrrrgh!"
"Cut!"
Nonsense!
Here's a blooper-stuffed take that made its
way into the final cut of Guardians of the
Galaxy.
While dealing with a rare goods dealer known
as the Broker, Yondu frustrates and upsets
the guy by mumbling a bunch of gibberish.
It's a little more than co-star Sea Gunn could
handle, and director James Gunn kept the result
in the film.
"The high-end…"
*babbles*
"It's a tight-knit…"
"The high-end community is a tight-knit…!"
More nonsense!
It's apparently no sweat for Michael Rooker
to make up his own real-sounding nonsense
words in a pinch.
But give the guy some comic book/science-fiction
movie dialogue heavy on the technical side,
and he just can't get the words out without
stumbling.
Whoops!
"Craglin, we need an extraction at…
UGH!
Quadrant.
Haha."
Lee Pace loses his place
Prior to joining the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
Lee Pace worked primarily an actor in more
straightforward dramas.
Those roles didn't necessarily prepare him
for the bonkers role of Ronan the Accuser,
as this blooper of Pace struggling to nail
the role shows.
"Wait, one more time, what was that?
There, and then turn?"
"POWER!
Becomes the only law!
Wait, that's not right, is it?"
Chris Pratt doinks around
Finally, the encounter between the Guardians
of the Galaxy and the alien ruler Ayesha drives
much of the conflict in the second film.
But it could have all gone very differently
if Star-Lord had gotten his way.
He didn't, but at least the effort left us
with this amazing gem.
"I personally control half the DNA by doing
something I call doinking."
"Hahah!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!